we are getting mixed signals tonight
from the White House about President
Trump's latest demand that the Russia
collusion probe be terminated early in
the day the president called on Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to pull the plug
on that investigation on Twitter but the
walk back began shortly thereafter chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
starts us off tonight as the often does
from the North Lawn good evening John
bracket evening to you and some
late-breaking news regarding the
possibility of an interview of President
Trump by robert muller the president's
outside legal team weeks ago had sent
Muller a list of conditions for an
interview as to what they would and
would not agree to well now they finally
heard back Fox News has learned that
Special Counsel Robert Muller has not
agreed to demands from president Trump's
attorneys to limit questioning to
matters of collusion that he still wants
to ask questions regarding obstruction
of justice and a few other topics one
concession from Muller according to
sources he has agreed to reduce the
number of questions from his initial
list of 49 and is willing to accept some
answers in writing though others he
still wants oral answers to sources say
talks with the special counsel continue
but add there is a long way to go Rudy
Giuliani told Fox News his inclination
is still to say no to an interview but
that President Trump wants him to keep
talking with Muller news of the Muller
response followed a tweet this morning
in which President Trump criticized the
investigation in his strongest language
yet the president tweeting this is a
terrible situation and Attorney General
Jeff Sessions should stop this rig
witch-hunt right now before it continues
to stain our country any further the
White House was quick to proclaim the
president was only airing his
frustration not telling sessions what to
do the president is stating his opinion
he's stating it clearly and he's
certainly expressing the frustration
that he has with the level of corruption
that we've seen from people like Jim
Comey Peter struck Andrew McCabe the
president may have simply been blowing
off steam as he has done many times in
the past but the net effect was to put
the spotlight squarely back on the
Russia investigation Democrat Adam
Schiff on Twitter proclaimed this
Damon was an attempt to obstruct justice
hiding in plain sight even Maine's
Republican senator Susan Collins found
the tweet ill-advised there's currently
no cause for firing mr. Muller and I
don't think it's going to happen
the president's tweeted some fortunate I
think it's inappropriate for him to be
commenting on an ongoing investigation
the president's lead outside counsel
Rudy Giuliani thought it necessary to
clarify the president's intent he's
established a clear sort of practice now
that he expresses his opinions on
Twitter he used the word should he
didn't use the word lost and there was
no presidential directive to follow them
as the White House was dialing back the
president's tweet it was ramping up the
trade dispute with China announcing
today that the next 200 billion dollars
in Chinese goods to be targeted by
tariffs could be taxed at a rate of 25%
more than double the initially proposed
10% the bottom line is the president's
going to continue to hold China
responsible for their unfair trade
practices this has gone on for long
enough and he's gonna do something about
it China's response was Swift and sharp
young wave under US pressure and
blackmail will not work if the US takes
further measures that escalate the
situation
China will definitely fight back the
White House calculates the battle this
way China buys about a hundred and
thirty billion dollars worth of goods
from the United States whereas the
United States buys more than five
hundred billion dollars worth of goods
every year from China so in an
escalating tit-for-tat
when it comes to tariffs the u.s.
believes it's got far more bullets in
its ammunition stores than China does
Brett John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thanks